[Music]
hey guys welcome to our installments of
Harry Potter theory in this video we're
going to be discussing Lord Voldemort
the Elder Wand in the death of Severus
Snape and Severus Snape died it was
truly a tragic moment as everything had
written balked at the surface about
Snipes true intentions Snape is arguably
one of the most dynamic characters in
the series and being a double agent for
all of those years deceiving Lord
Voldemort was a massively impressive
feat as we progress through the books
from films our perception of Snape is
constantly challenged is he good bad
what are his intentions in the end Snape
was one of the best people around and
his death was massively significant in
franchise we know that Snape ultimately
dies at the hands or mouth rather of
Nagini on Voldemort orders what was
unusual in this scene was that Voldemort
is a massive proponent of Avada Kedavra
he can't get enough of it and it's very
purpose is to kill so why wouldn't he
use Avada Kedavra on Snape why would he
get Nagini to finish him off there are a
couple of reasons why from the books why
doesn't it work for me Severus in the
silence
Harry imagined he could hear the snake
hissing slightly as it coiled a nun
coiled or was it Voldemort sibilants I
lingering on the air but my lord said
Snape blankly I do not understand you
you have performed extraordinary magic
with that wand no said Voldemort I have
performed my usual magic
I am extraordinary but this wand no it
has not revealed the wonders it has
promised I feel no difference between
this one and the one I procured from
Ollivander all those years ago
Voldemort stone was musing calm but
Harry's scar had been in to throb and
pulse pain was building in his forehead
and he could feel that controlled sense
of fury building inside Voldemort this
excerpt depicts Voldemort puzzlement
with why his newly acquired Elder Wand
feels no different than any other wand
that he has possessed essentially Gollum
believes it because Snape killed
Dumbledore the elder ones allegiance
lies with Snape and that because the
elder one didn't show allegiance to him
he just felt like any other wand
Baltimore deduces that because Snape
killed Dumbledore that the elder one has
allegiance to Snape and that by killing
Snape its allegiance will switch over to
him the Elder Wand cannot serve me
properly Severus because I'm not its
true master the elder one belonged to
the wizard who killed its last owner you
killed Albus Dumbledore while you live
Severus the Elder Wand cannot truly be
mine however Volant is hesitant as he
doesn't want to risk his plan backfiring
Valen believes that the wand would not
be capable of killing its true owner so
he uses another method one that is
convenient and effective Nagini one
other reason that Voldemort may have not
used avada kedavra on Snape is that he
didn't really want to kill him at least
not personally to be able to cast the
killing curse you must really hate
someone and I think that Voldemort may
have just had a little bit too much
respect for Snape to kill him
sure Voldemort was a sociopath but I
think that he really appreciated Snape
in a weird way you can't perform an
unforgivable curse like Avada Kedavra
without proper intent this is explained
in the following excerpt never use Sinan
for Givi will curse before have you boy
she yelled she had abandoned her baby
voice now you need to mean them water
you need to really want to cause pain to
enjoy it righteous anger won't hurt me
for long I'll show you how it's done
shall I I'll give you a lesson those
were of course the words of Bellatrix to
Harry and those are the two reasons that
I think that Voldemort never used avada
kedavra on Snape and that's it for this
video I hope you enjoyed it until next
time you're a wizard Harry
[Music]